[Music]
new drug may cure cancer aspirin may
reduce risk of heart attacks eating
breakfast can help you lose weight
health headlines like these flood the
news often contradicting each other
so how can you figure out what's a
genuine health concern or a truly
promising remedy and what's less
conclusive
in medicine there's often a disconnect
between news headlines and the
scientific research they cover
that's because a headline is designed to
catch attention it's most effective when
it makes a big claim
by contrast many scientific studies
produce meaningful results when they
focus on a narrow specific question
the best way to bridge this gap is to
look at the original research behind a
headline
we've come up with a simplified research
scenario for each of these three
headlines to test your skills
keep watching for the explanation of the
first study then pause at the headline
to figure out the flaw assume all the
information you need to spot the flaw is
included
let's start with this hypothetical
scenario a study using mice to test a
new cancer drug the study includes two
groups of mice one treated with the drug
the other with a placebo at the end of
the trial the mice that receive the drug
are cured while those that received the
placebo are not
can you spot the problem with this
headline
study shows new drug could cure cancer
since the subjects of the study were
mice we can't draw conclusions about
human disease based on this research
in real life early research on new drugs
and therapies is not conducted on humans
if the early results are promising
clinical trials follow to determine if
they hold up in humans
now that you've warmed up let's try a
trickier example a study about the
impact of aspirin on heart attack risk
the study randomly divides a pool of men
into two groups the members of one group
take aspirin daily while the others take
a daily placebo
by the end of the trial the control
group suffered significantly more heart
attacks than the group that took aspirin
based on this situation what's wrong
with the headline aspirin may reduce
risk of heart attacks
in this case the study shows evidence
that aspirin reduces heart attacks in
men because all the participants were
men but the conclusion aspirin reduces
risk of heart attacks is too broad we
can't assume that results found in men
would also apply to women
studies often limit participants based
on geographic location age gender or
many other factors
before these findings can be generalized
similar studies need to be run on other
groups
if a headline makes a general claim it
should draw its evidence from a diverse
body of research not one study
can you take your skills from the first
two questions to the next level try this
example about the impact of eating
breakfast on weight loss
researchers recruit a group of people
who had always skipped breakfast and
asked them to start eating breakfast
every day the participants include men
and women of a range of ages and
backgrounds over a year-long period
participants lose an average of five
pounds so what's wrong with the headline
eating breakfast can help you lose
weight
the people in the study started eating
breakfast and lost weight but we don't
know that they lost weight because they
started eating breakfast
perhaps having their weight tracked
inspired them to change their eating
habits in other ways
to rule out the possibility that some
other factor caused weight loss we would
need to compare these participants to a
group who didn't eat breakfast before
the study and continued to skip it
during the study a headline certainly
shouldn't claim the results of this
research are generally applicable
and if the study itself made such a
claim without a comparison group then
you should question its credibility
now that you've battle tested your
skills on these hypothetical studies and
headlines you can test them on real
world news even when full papers aren't
available without a fee you can often
find summaries of experimental design
and results in freely available
abstracts or even within the text of a
news article
individual studies have results that
don't necessarily correspond to a grabby
headline big conclusions for human
health issues require lots of evidence
accumulated over time but in the
meantime we can keep on top of the
science by reading past the headlines
continue sharpening your media literacy
skills with these videos
[Music]
you